i am
raghavendran
bioinformatics mentor with find biotech
and i welcome you all to this overview
session on the summer 22 homicide
training programs so this part of this
session will give you more detail and
additional details about the program
design about the curriculum and about
resources
so uh
as you know this summer we have a range
of programs that you can look into
further and register
so that you can learn a little bit more
about bioinformatics and how it is
applied to various different uh
topics related to biology and
bioinformatics
so this this program will generally be
offered virtually around the topics of
infectious diseases
it also includes
coding in r and in python it also
includes bioinformatics analysis of gene
expression data in transfectomics
and in general introduction to big data
bioinformatics
so this
program will actually help you to
complete a research uh at the end of
this we also have a research fellowship
program and dr mohit will talk more
about this research fellowship program
so this research fellowship program is
is specifically designed to help you
complete a project leveraging public
domain data from using big data
infrastructure and
and exploiting training and support from
all of us from our team and our mentors
so let's go
to little bit more detail about these
programs
one by one and understand what they
offer to students and faculties
so
we start with introduction to
bioinformatics where we actually uh
introduce you to the big part of
that
can you hear me
can you mute yes thank you very much yes
sir you can proceed further
shiram can you put your query in the
chat please please answer your query
towards the end of the session thank you
so much
over to you sir
yes thank you very much
please
yeah
please put your queries and enter your
queries in the chat i'm following chat
as i'm
chatting with you
so uh
so let me
share again
okay
so the introduction to bioinformatics
program is designed to introduce you to
the world of big data biology and
data science tools
so it starts with the basics of next
generation sequencing and it starts with
what are the different omics data types
that you will be learning and what are
the different omics data types that are
used generally to understand the biology
and different biology of the system from
molecular level it also extends to what
are the
analysis methods and options that we
have to
use for or to uh
to employ on different omics data types
so that we can extract the maximum
information from these data types okay
somebody says that my voice is so feeble
let me uh sound up thank you very much
so in the end by the end of this big
data informatics program you'll also get
an introduction to how to use uh how to
apply advanced statistical methods like
machine learning and deep learning to
the structured data that we generate
from this next generation sequencing
data so in the end you will achieve all
of your achievements will be summarizing
in certificates that you can share with
your
peers
so
yeah
this you went through we have several
extensive training materials uh
prepared for you like associated courses
lessons from omixlogic platform
asynchronous videos live hands-on demo
sessions and we also have prepared
curated example projects
and
which takes
a publication and the data associated
with the publication to um
to an analysis method of its own and and
walks you through the whole process of
from the dataset through this uh through
specifically designed analysis methods
for the data set and biological
interpretation and conclusion and
comparison with the original
findings and we also have um
in the research fellowship program that
you will you will hear today so we
promote project-based uh learning and
interactive sessions for exploring
bioinformatics as uh as a as an option
so we also have uh several uh lessons
which are coding lessons that um that
have that is structured in an
interactive fashion so that you can
explore coding for bioinformatics
so the analysis methods that we have
discussed or that we have in
that we have in hand for different omics
data
are
are usually applied or employed in two
approaches so one of the approaches for
code independent uh approach is is for
those who who does not want to venture
into the world of coding and who is not
very comfortable in coding
so these methods these code
independent infrastructure methods will
include hands-on exercises in our big
data bioinfo platform like tbio info
platform and this provides a simple and
intuitive user interface for processing
analysing analyzing uh and
digital data
and uh different structural uh
structure data also so we can employ all
different kinds of analysis methods here
you will get a five terabyte storage so
that you can store your data that
usually is huge when you involve big
data by informatics and you will get
support from us and you will also get um
and get all the necessary associated
resources investing and videos so that
you can set up your analysis pipeline
independently and
and vary the methods in the analysis
pipeline to suit your data so this
analysis pipelines include both the
analysis of next generation sequencing
data to arrive at a structured table to
structure data or a structural list of
variants
and then from there it will also uh it
also includes a downstream analysis of
whatever you have generated the
structured data that you have generated
so that the downstream analysis applies
various statistical methods machine
learning methods so that you can infer
and explore the meaningful relationships
that is buried deep within your data
so
here is an example of the code
independent pipeline that i was talking
about and this pipeline builder
interface in the in the tbio info
platform is color coded um
so that you can establish a connection
between a logical connection between how
your analysis methods are
progressing and the data input is an
input file and the analysis can be
chosen based on the type of research and
the type of question that you are going
to ask we usually have three basic
colors that separates the analysis
methods blue is for preprocessing red is
for mapping and green is for
quantification and you can explore
oranges for downstream analysis the
interactive output we we also have
option for interactive output which
allows for easy visualization of the
data outputs and there are several demo
pipelines which will um which will give
you an experience of setting up an
original pipeline and downloading the
output associated output
to get a feel for how to set up big data
bioinfo
informatics pipeline for next generation
sequencing data and for downstream
analysis and what are the different kind
of outputs that you will get and how you
can make sense of this output in the
connotation with the biological
relevance or phenotypical association of
the samples
yeah so this is part of the interactive
output so for those who want to
expand your skill sets to coding and
venture into the into learning coding
along with their analysis we have
lessons that involve coding and these
lessons are divided into
into several steps so the first one of
first step is always to understand the
context or the aim of the analysis and
it follows it is followed with the logic
behind the analysis that we are
performing and then we have a learn the
code section
yeah
learn the code section but each and
every parts of this code are
explained to you uh in a in
in a small piece by piece manner and
finally you'll have practice the course
section where you can practice whatever
you have learned and then in the end you
will have option to download or you'll
have option to access the full code
document in a jupyter notebook or a
google call up notebook format so that
you can independently modify the code to
suit your analysis or data requirements
so each session is actually planned uh
for for an hour-long
video and you will have
more associated resources that you have
to go through and i think our sonalika
will actually talk more about uh
how much you should spend for each and
each and every one of these sessions so
that you can gain or get maximum
information from these sessions or
resourceful discussions
so yeah
so
for our next
program we have biomedical data analysis
using r and python so the introduction
to bioinformatics section will introduce
you to the different analysis methods
but if you want to delve deep into the
into the world of data analysis and data
science of bio omics data or big or
mixed data then you have to choose an
option like this so in this
program for example the focus is on uh
learning data science and not
programming so programming we use as a
tool to learn data science the more
focus and emphasis is on understanding
the logic behind the methods and
tweaking certain part of the programming
or of the code blocks so that it suits
your
data or your analysis methods so
yeah
so why do we choose only python and r so
we know that python and r are the major
resources that is used for
bioinformatics data analysis and i don't
want to create any
war between
people who like python and people who
like her so we are on the fence or we
are we are of uh
of um of an opinion that it is not a
good idea as a bioinformatics enthusiast
or or for data science enthusiasts to
pigeonhole yourself into one of these
methods both have their advantage and
both have their shortcomings
so you should learn enough of enough
concepts from both the tools as much as
you can so that you can apply either one
of them depending upon the type of data
depending upon the type of analysis that
you use and that is what we also promote
for most of the lessons that you have we
have all these um analysis methods
divided into three parts the first part
as i actually
actually mentioned earlier it's code
independent block where you can get the
experience of performing these analysis
using the big data bio info platform and
the second portion is the running the
same analysis in an environment like r
and the third one is using environment
like python so you will have um
complementary information from all these
three different resources
so we first start with the basics of
getting started with r and python where
we start absolutely from the basic like
how to load the data into our
environment or how to load a file into
python's environment which is
which is absolutely the most necessary
skill that you want to have if you want
to use r and python for bioinformatics
data analysis and then we up the up the
ante with trying to analyze or trying to
read dna sequences and how to compare
dna sequences in r and python and how to
uh
how to take your first steps into
bioinformatics data analysis so all of
the data that is discussed and all of
the data that you are going to load are
from
from either of the omics data
specifically prepared and specially
preferred for you to run all these
analysis in your uh
in the interactive platform that you
will learn are in your our studio that
you have locally installed our python
environment that you have locally
installed in your
in your computer
and we uh and then to increase
the applications of r and python into
the world of data science we have
several different data processing and
visualization and advanced visualization
methods that you will get hands on to
and how different visualization is also
going to help you learn about the
patterns that you can generally observe
from the data it's just not
you run this code boom you get a scatter
plot if you run this code you get a
histogram but more emphasis is on what
are you going to learn from histogram
and why is histogram a better option
when compared to scatter plot so more of
these kind of discussion is what we will
be having
this one so to to start uh from the from
the from absolute basic you always have
to start from somewhere so we we have to
give you an uh a detailed introduction
in in the first lesson or introduction
into the introduction to bioinformatic
analysis in r about some of the concepts
that you will mostly use or you will use
frequently in your data analysis like um
what are the different objects like data
frame under array and metrics that you
will be using for your omix data
analysis what are the different basic
functions like how to find the dimension
of the array how to find the size of
some of the elements and how to find
that
how to
index or take specific portions from the
data frame or how to restructure data
frame basic on your based on your uh
requirements so all of these would be
covered extensively up at the start and
then as you progress uh in in the
program so these will be
used repetitively
so that you can get a feeling for how
these are used in the or mix data
analysis so you can you can you can say
that we
in in python or in our
world we actually quickly
introduce you
after your data exploration and data
loading and transforming you we quickly
introduce you to advanced statistical
methods like machine learning and
with supervised and unsupervised machine
learning and comparing different uh
supervised classification algorithm and
etcetera so this is this is in bio ml
cores in python which
and and also available in r which
compares a different machine learning
methods for the same or similar data so
that you can clearly get a get an
understanding of
how
same or similar analysis methods
interpret the pattern that is
that you can find or that is that is
available in the data that is present in
the data
so always you start with load and
transform and start exploring the data
and then before uh going into further uh
analysis methods so all of these methods
will actually take the structured data
that i was talking to you about so this
this is a table output tabular output
that you can generally
get access to from publicly available
data set or if you have next generation
sequencing data you can get to the
structured data from um
from running one of those pipelines that
we have discussed before and you will
also see one more example of that
so the practical coding assignments in
uh in our learn
in the portal on portal is designed in
such a way that it will help you to
understand that different elements of
code are
from coding python for example this is
an example of interactive console that
we are going to offer you for both
python and our environment where you
will have your code uh
where you you'll have the code that you
can write on the console and then the
console will uh
and the right portion of the console
will uh will be that will be where it is
being executed and
and then
interactive output is going to be uh
printed out and you will also have if
you have a codes to prepare or if you
have codes to print out plots and the
plots will also appear below so this is
embedded into each and every one of
these coding lessons so that whatever
you have achieved in learning the code
section you can apply it in into this
practice the code area uh so and and we
also gave you we also have um some more
test your
ability to fill up the codes where we
modify some of the
some of the
coding
coding
codes so that too uh so that you can
complete those syntaxes and we
deliberately leave out some parts of the
code so that you can
you can
access yourself or you can try to
complete those course and and
learn from these learn the code
separation area so once you are through
with the practice
section where you have completed these
codes successfully and these practice
sections are designed in such a way to
increase the level of difficulties and
once you are through you will be given
either
an option to perform an assignment or
complete an assignment
or
you will be given access to
google collaboratory notebook or jupiter
kind of jupyter notebook kind of
link where you can get all the codes
that are discussed in the lesson and
little bit more more other options also
so you can get a feeling for running the
code um either one by one or in unison
from start to and and you also since you
have the access you also have the
freedom to play with the code to change
the analysis methods to compare one
method with the other one and etc
so
as i as i mentioned at the start we
don't focus on making you learn
programming
um
we don't focus on making you learn
programming but we let you understand
the data science aspect of the
programming so
how different strategies of these
analysis work together and how
how by employing different data
processing methods will help you define
the hypothesis will help you refine the
hypothesis and will help you prepare the
data for meaningful applications most of
the time in in the data science
application method most of the time
spent in this this past in this portion
and this portion the data analysis and
summary of statistics will take only uh
very um
will take limited amount of your time
unlimited amount of your coding uh areas
so go back i think yeah so most of the
time you're going to spend in processing
cleaning and pre-processing the input
data such that it fits the
analysis requirements of it fits the
statistical requirements of different
analysis methods and data mining and
visualization and exploratory analysis
perform very important part key portion
in refining your hypothesis you look for
pattern if that pattern is is present
then you refine your hypothesis or if if
some of the initial early exploratory
visualization provides you with a
different
different idea or a different view so
you expand on that we go in that
direction that's the power of data
science we don't start with the fixed
hypothesis we explore the data for
available hypothesis and then we keep
refining the hypothesis so that our data
can explore the
explore the
relationships in in the in the features
or in the genes or in different
different aspects of different portions
of the data to reject or accept uh or to
evaluate the hypothesis so i have a
question where um before going next when
using code written by someone else there
are concerns about copyright issues and
whether it is necessary to get coders
permission to copyright
so if the if you are getting the code or
if you're downloading the code from the
coders computer without their uh without
their knowledge then of course you have
to get permission but there are codes
which are left for you to explore in the
freely available
resources like github or in google
collaboratory so
in these portions you can just mention
modified from this code so that you are
being a good person and then
acknowledging from that the code source
has been taken from and most of the
publication nowadays require you or
require the authors to give link to
their code so that people can reproduce
their results so once they give a
permission or once they upload the code
in in downloadable
public resources and repositories like
google collaboratory or sorry google
collabs and in um and then github then
it is free for you to take
provided that you acknowledge them
accordingly so we whenever you want to
take codes written by somebody please
acknowledge and this is a code that that
is taken from this link and it is
modified to suit this specific uh
concern this specific analysis
okay
so so the difference between uh
for example choosing a specific omics
data analysis track and choosing okay i
went back again sorry choosing specific
omics data analysis track and program
and choosing
data science programming data science
track is that
in the data science track you will get
you will you will have experience in
dealing with dealing with the structured
data that is generated from variety of
different
omics data analysis you can get either
transcriptomics data you can get a list
of variants in the genomics data and you
can get abundance information abundance
table from the metagenomics
which one of these data structure data
that you can get your hands on requires
different
concoction or different
combinations of programming methods and
so that
you can
explore the variety of patterns that is
that is associated in the data that is
buried deep in the data so this can be
as simple as
the analysis can be as simple as
performing a teachers in excel or as
complex as performing uh hierarchical
clustering or
unsupervised clustering and then
followed by
supervised classification for different
of the different one of these clusters
so it can go from very simple methods to
even complex and complicated